well the Duke of Sussex has been a very
good uncle to three young children from
his brother and sister-in-law and I
think that remembering his own childhood
and his much-loved mother and the sense
of being a father and especially after
being a soldier that whole aspiration to
settle down you find somebody madly
loves and I think every one of us who
understands that passion and delight
that you find in another person the
obvious process after a wedding like
that glorious one we all saw at Windsor
is that this should finally come to pass
the first child in a family and it it is
something I think when you watch and see
two people with their first child be
delight is always so real it's a sort of
realization every element why they are
together and what is so natural about
that stands as we've been speaking to
you we've been reporting sky sources but
and we bucking the palace has now
officially announced that the Duchess of
Sussex has gone into labor an Alastair
role commentator and an expert in all
things royal and seventh in line to the
throne in this this baby's chances of
ever of ever really getting there are
very very slim are they well one hopes
not because the implication of course is
so profound I think that the nature of a
hereditary monarchy is that there is a
security and constancy established by
the order of succession but on the whole
there are no great surprises and the
eldest son of the eldest son or the
eldest child of the eldest son goes on
to become sovereign as we now have after
the six sessions of the crime Act I
would imagine that there is very little
likelihood in fact as time goes by the
children of the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex will become moderately less and
less relevant as the nation will focus
on any children that Prince George has
and that Prince George's children have
because that's the nature of how the
process works but for now it's really
exciting that for the Queen another
great grandchild and for the royal
family
another new life to celebrate and for
the nation to who feel at certain
element of ownership of the royal family
it's a sense that there is a name deed
another child coming into that great
story and not an HRH because so far down
the line well george v wrote a very
clear set of instructions in 1917 which
restricted the prefix Royal Highness to
the children and grandchildren of the
sovereign so at birth this child is a
great grandchild and therefore will take
the style and title of the child of a
Duke and Duchess and we'll see if it's a
boy or if it's a girl which of those
stars sometimes they'll take but in due
course the child of the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex will be the grandchild of a
sovereign because after the demise of
the Queen there will be a new king and
then they will become Royal Highnesses
but that's really up to the family
because all Prince Edward the Earl of
Wessex and for thir his two children are
entitled to be a royal highnesses but
they don't call themselves that I think
partly because the parents felt it would
be easier in life and not to be burdened
by that kind of name